[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
accelerating microscopy image analysis
with ai
i am kayleigh bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems
to learn more visit
leica-microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
juan young choi phd
avia product manager product owner leica
avia
one young you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is wan yong choi and i'm
the product manager product owner for
leicas avia software
thank you very much for joining me today
for this webinar
we'll be showing you
how you can incorporate ai into your
microscope image analysis for
accelerated insight generation
today
i'll be showing you
avi 11 key features focused on
accessible artificial intelligence for
scientists which include
whole experiment support from multi-well
import navigation tagging of
experimental conditions
generalist deep learning cell
segmentation based on cell pose for 2d
3d cell segmentation for a wide range of
cell types and microscopy modalities
workflows where you can build enhanced
batch processors from history
spatial biology tools via cytomap
integration where you can output abs
measurements for advanced analysis tools
such as dimensionality reduction machine
learning based data clustering heat map
and hierarchical gating
in addition we'll be talking about avl
web which now includes permanent storage
in the cloud
ai is becoming an increasingly larger
part of our daily lives
you may have seen this in your own life
as in the case of a robotic weight staff
or self-driving cars that are growing in
prominence
there are other examples where ai is
deeply involved in your life in ways you
may not be aware of as in the case of
robots and industrial applications as
you see here in spot by boston dynamics
that explores dangerous underground
conditions
or in medical settings where companies
are racing to find ai diagnostic and
therapeutic tools for various diseases
and conditions
we also see this in the biological
community embracing ai as shown here by
the exponential growth in the use of ai
in the biological sciences
the number of publications with a.i and
biology or neuroscience in the last 20
years have grown over 360 percent
in the first half year of 2022 the
publication numbers have already
surpassed
the total number of publications in the
entire year in 2015
with the help of ai scientists in
various disciplines are increasingly
getting productive and get to more
accurate results faster
with more innovative deep learning
models being introduced and were getting
refined
this trend will only increase such that
we can anticipate researchers will
likely be using a growing number of ai
assisted tools to further accelerate
their past to groundbreaking discoveries
avia has been in the forefront of
enabling biological discoveries fueled
by ai based image analysis
built on the foundation of over 32
patents in machine learning and computer
vision over the last 20 years
the avia team located here in the
seattle leica innovation hub has created
multiple innovative tools to help
researchers worldwide to get insights
faster with greater accuracy
with avl 5 the avia team introduced
neuron and spine analysis and machine
learning object classifier followed by
deep learning model for em images in
avs6
machine learning pixel classifier seven
3d cell tracking and lineage tracing in
avia 8
deep image restoration python
integration and cloud-based avia for
accessibility for all in avian 9.
in 2021 we introduced aviada learns
which is a deep learning based object
detection tool for easy to use ai
without knowledge or
of coding or machine learning
with avia 10.5 introduced in february of
2022
we expanded aviada learns for neuron
analysis where
there's over 73 percent reduction in
time needed to generate optimized
parameters for neuron tracing assisted
by ai
using our built-in optional telemetry
feature users data can help us to
further refine our predictive model for
continuous improvement
for avi 11 that we're launching today we
wanted to create tools that would
increase productivity and efficiency
from multiple different angles
first we tackled the well-known
challenges for cell segmentation where
there's often a trade-off for
flexibility or automation
while many tools out there offer great
level of flexibility they might require
full manual labeling and thus are time
consuming
on the other end of the spectrum there
may be fully automated tools based on
deep neural networks with parameters
estimated on large training data sets
however these tools may be trained on
specialized data sets and may not
generalize well to other types of data
cell pose published in nature methods in
2020 is a generalist deep learning based
segmentation algorithm that can be that
can segment wide range of images from
cells published by carson stringer at
all from maria's pakitario lab at
genealia
in brief
this model uses two major innovations
reversible transformation from training
set masks to vector flows that can be
predicted by a unit-based neural network
and a large segmented data set of varied
images ranging from biological to
non-biological across different
microscopy modalities
in this image you're seeing a t's knee
output which shows the wide variety of
data sets used to build the model
to briefly describe the model
architecture in the training set
manually annotated mass sets were
transformed via heat diffusion
simulation to derive spatial gradients
to generate flow representation as you
see
here then a unet-based neural network is
trained to predict the flow field based
on horizontal
vertical flow
and lastly probability of pixels inside
cells
the predictive flow fields are used to
construct the predictive masks in the
final step
for avi 11 we have integrated the 2d
probability map generated by cell posts
into the existing avl workflow for ease
to use deep learning cell segmentation
there are four new cell pose based tools
that are created within the avia
they are 3d cell analysis with cell pose
recipe
cell count cell post recipe both of
which output objects
cell post enhancement
image enhancement tool that outputs
a confidence map
and lastly cell post object detection
image enhancement tool
that outputs masks
cell posts has been demonstrated to
generate accurate cell segmentation for
varied cell types for nucleus
membrane
and cytoplasmic stain for dic and
fluorescent images
our benchmarking data show an average
speed improvement of over 80 percent for
this integrated image analysis pipeline
compared to the python interface to
south post for which avia was the first
commercial entity to do so in avia 8.8
so you're seeing this very significant
speed improvement
with the current iteration that's a
fully integrated
cell post into avs pipeline
here are some segmentation examples with
avia with cell posts where this model
can accurately segment various cell
types for membrane
nucleus
and cytoplasmic stains
here are some examples of the types of
diverse image types cell posts can
handle
for example biological medicine images
from cell image library and additional
images from various microscopy
techniques and object types including
fruits vegetables fish scales and so on
cell post has been demonstrated to
segment diverse cell types with higher
accuracy than stardust and mask rcnn
here's an example from a challenging
data set where cell posts can accurately
segment membrane stained cells
then using avs cell analysis recipe the
nucleus and vesicles can be segmented
with spatial measurements such as
vesicles vesicle distance from the
nucleus or the membrane
this is a 3d image of intestinal
organoid courtesy of dr andreas moore a
dth zoric
the second feature we've implemented to
increase productivity and efficiency is
our newly built experiment explorer
that enables multi-well image import
with this tool we've enabled annotation
of wells with different experimental
conditions such that drug dosage or
genotype of the cells can be tagged so
that you can perform downstream advanced
analysis
in addition
we've created a flexible customizable
workflow processor for enhanced batch
processing that incorporates
all the analysis tools available in avia
such as image enhancement functions
ai powered pixel classifier deep
learning models image analysis recipes
and object classifier into a single
workflow
you can now analyze your image using avs
built-in tools on a single field of view
and build an analysis pipeline using the
new workflow tool
the analysis workflow you built can then
be batch applied to your entire imaging
experiment or just on select wells with
your annotated conditions
lastly we've created a data export
function for advanced data exploration
for this
i'll show you an example using cytomap a
spatial analysis tool for cells regions
and tissues created by caleb stozofas at
all at michael gerner's lab at
university of washington
and cytomap was published in cell
reports in 2020
cytomev enables cellular patterning
distance analysis
spatial correlation and dimensionality
reduction techniques among others
and avia users can now export out
measurements per condition per analyzed
objects from avia for advanced in-depth
analysis
here are some interesting examples you
can achieve using cytomap
on the left
you're seeing an example with umap
dimensionality reduction that reduces
multiple parameters down to two
to allow for visualization of complex
data sets and subsequent hierarchical
gating of different population of cells
for further analysis
on the right you're seeing an example a
pearson correlation coefficient that
visually demonstrates where meaningful
correlations may lie for the
measurements for different drug
conditions for the cell objects that are
analyzing the avia in this example
there are various advanced tools
available inside a map and umap is one
such example um is a non-linear
dimensionality reduction technique that
allows users to create
two new parameters from a high
dimensional data set for visualization
and analysis
you can see an example this woolly
mammoth in 3d that can be reduced using
umap using different parameters
using this
along with other advanced features
inside a map avia users can tackle
complex data sets to generate insights
faster
our new experiment explorer can be used
for images on slides such as this mouse
coronal brain section for segmentation
with an avia and downstream analysis
inside a map
now we'll be moving on to avia for demo
of all the features
now i'll be moving into avia to show you
these features starting with cell pose
in this first example i have the large
intestine organoid sample that i showed
you briefly within my presentation it's
a very nice 3d stack
with three channels for membrane
vesicles and
nucleus in the interest of time i'll be
moving onto a corrupt smaller data set
which i'll be using to show you the
workflow and show you the final output
in this small data set as you can see we
see very clear membrane stain and
the nucleus stain actually isn't quite
as ideal in this particular example but
as you will see shortly the pose
algorithm actually can handle both types
of signals in this in this particular
example
what i'm showing you here is in the
within the recipe we've introduced two
new recipes the first one is the 3d
object analysis cell pose that reads 3d
data and outputs an object
the second one is cell count cell pose
that works for 2d images outputs an
object in addition we've introduced two
new additional image enhancement tools
that's
available under the image enhancement
tool tab
the first is a cell post enhancement
option that outputs a confidence map
the second option is a cell post object
detection option that i'll put a mask
in this example
i'm going to be choosing the cell post
enhancement option to generate a
confidence map
for the membrane and for the nucleus
and feed them both into the existing
3d
cell analysis
recipe with an avia
i'm changing my input to green
and choosing the correct model in this
case
for the membrane is actually model
number three which is based on cytomap
two
now
in this particular option you do need to
input the size of a typical object
diameter
for this i'm getting out of the 3d view
to 2d view then choosing the annotation
option to measure the diameter of a cell
this is roughly about 4 microns so i'm
going to input that value
and apply to the current frame so here's
a confidence map that's been generated
i'm going to adjust the lookup table so
you could see the objects better
to me it looks
like a really great
confidence
output
so i'm going to be using this into the
recipe now i've actually run a similar
process for the nucleus as well
so now moving into 3d cell analysis
meshes recipe
so for the cell input i'm choosing the
newly created cytoplasm confidence map
that you just saw
then for the nucleus i'm also inputting
the nucleus confidence map
for the first step
of whole cell detection
i'm going to be turning off all the
other channels the confidence map
channels so that i can see the output
better the preview output better
so this is an example of what the whole
cell detection would look like shows the
objects are segmented
and moving on to the next item i'm going
to actually detect nucleus in a similar
way
you'll see these options all have
different sliders that you could adjust
cell diameter
using the same
method i just showed you with the
annotation tool to get a size estimation
then enter as as you need we recommend
for the cell post algorithm that you
turn off all
smoothing and background subtraction to
start with and add on these options as
you go
for the nucleus data i'm actually
choosing to remove background because my
preliminary output showed that in this
particular example where as i mentioned
to you the nucleus data wasn't as well
defined
having the background removal actually
resulted in better segmentation
that looks pretty good and now we're
moving on to the vesicle detection step
so again i'm turning on the preview
channel
and
it looks pretty good to me in terms of
the placement of the vesicles
you do have the option to actually um
apply partition for the vesicles based
on the size
and in this example i've skipped
background subtraction and image
smoothing
now once i'm happy with the parameter i
run for the entire stack and here's my
output
i can adjust the color map here to case
i'll choose color by name that shows
you all the different cells in different
colors when you see the objects placed
inside the the membrane signal you could
see that the actual cells are pretty
well segmented for the vesicle i'm gonna
actually color by measurement and choose
in this case color by measurement
and choose measurement distance to
nearest edge of nucleus
let's see how that looks and this is the
color map we get
so this is essentially how you go
through the sell post avia recipe
workflow
now i will show you how
it looks on the entire image that could
take several minutes depending on the
size of the data
in this original image where i've
applied the exact same steps i've shown
you on the entire image you can see the
detected objects
that there's an example of the
confidence map that i'm showing you
right now
it looks
very robust and doing a great job of
segmenting already at the confidence map
level
and i'm showing you here the detected
objects for the membrane
bound
cytoplasm as well as
the nucleus and the vesicles
here's another example of 3d organoid
where we employed a similar strategy of
generating a confidence map using cell
posts then using the 3d cell analysis
recipe with an avia
that was a brief introduction to cell
pose and how we use cell host with an
avia to get you more accurate cell
segmentation
now we'll move on to the second feature
of av11 which is
the new experiment explorer which
enables you to tag different conditions
within different wells on the multi-well
plate
and enable you to do downstream advanced
analytics via cytomap
you can import your multi-well file
formats in leica lift file format
or import a previously saved experiment
av experiment file format directly into
the experiment explorer
the way you navigate through this
interface is
quite intuitive you click on the well
then you can see the number of fields of
views there in this example
you're seeing four fields of view per
well
right now i'm showing you how you can
tag different
columns of wells into um same
experimental condition group in this
case drug
and no agonist
in this experiment we actually had two
experimental conditions so the now i'm
tagging the second condition
for columns seven to twelve with the
agonist condition
now i'll select the first two wells in
each condition to actually denote them
to be my second
condition
so that i can just run batch on these
few wells in the interest of time
so i've done that now moving on to the
data set there are actually three
channels in each image but i'm going to
be using only the first
two channels for this demonstration
[Music]
as you can see here you can see quite a
number of punctate objects
this is an experiment where defective
agonist on the number of punctate
objects will be measured then i'm
actually changing the the input channel
as the green channel
then i'm actually changing the color of
the
wand pixel class into pink so that you
can see it better so the way the pixel
classifier works is you train the
software with a simple
stroke in this case i'm actually
training the software to recognize
background
and
i'm actually including
some of my signal in this particular
example and the reason for that is to
capture the background area around my
want signal as close closely as possible
so i've done the training you could see
how quickly the pixel classifier can
detect bright punctate spots based on
the simple training we have machine
learning now that i've trained the
software get this one channel that will
be then used in the next step
you notice that with the pixel
classifier the object in this in this
instance i haven't uh spent a lot of
time to train
uh the pixel classifier to
make the punctate objects as discrete
objects
but that actually does not matter in
this case because we're going to feed
this into the cell analysis recipe that
can actually handle that downstream
so right now i'm actually
putting cell um
input as a green channel the nucleus is
a blue then vesicle channel as the
newly created channel called want
now i'm going to run a quick cell
detection preview in this case it's a
very much similar interface as what
you've seen in the past you can actually
specify the
cell diameter typical cell diameter
which you can measure using the
annotation tool then you can input that
you can choose to remove the background
or add smoothing as i've shown you in
the past in this case i've actually
worked on the parameters so that you
could see that you could detect
the boundaries of the cells
then now i'll move on to the nucleus
detection step where i am detecting the
nuclei
looking pretty good there
then
i move on to
the last vesicle detection step
now this is the
step where i fed the pixel
classification
step to feed in the channel and you can
see in this example
that
those vesicles are actually separated
into different discrete objects so you
could do per object analysis and you can
get per object measurements
now i've run the entire recipe you could
see that the objects are detected in
this in this example i'm now going to
color code cell membrane by name so that
you could see the different
cells in different colors
adjusting the transparency so you could
see through
and you can also in this case create a
workflow
as you saw here
by right clicking
on the object
itself you can create a newly created
our new new feature um that's the
workflow processor with an avi 11.
what this workflow flow processor does
is it's an enhanced batch processor that
actually enables you to
input your experimental conditions that
you've just created in the step where
where i didn't put it the drug condition
for example saved as an experiment file
format you can input that along with
the condition that was used to create
those detected objects
into this batch workflow you can then
save that as a workflow file and you
cannot actually add different images
reuse that workflow file add different
experimental files you could actually
sequentially chain a number of different
workflows so that one runs after the
other in this example i'll show you i'm
actually i'm putting a tag filter so
that i can only i only run
the workflow on the four wells that i've
specified
in this example you're going to
recognize that there's a number of
different options for export
functionality there's the option to
export into excel there's an option to
export into the csv file format
that second format is quite important
downstream if you want to export it out
to another analysis software that you
may interface with in our example today
i'll be using cytomap as an example to
perform advanced analytics
so i'll choose a csv function there
moving on to the editor this is where
you could put
your notes about the experimental
conditions in this case i'm
changing the name of the
workflow file i am changing the name of
each analysis as a field of view
i'm also inputting my name there
this is actually a step where you input
number of different conditions that went
into doing your analysis
this by creating the workflow by right
clicking on the objects it's auto filled
in for you which is a very nice feature
in this case we're using the pixel
classifier i've shown you as the
pre-processing step
then using a recipe i built which was
the 2d
cell analysis recipe
and all the other information is auto
filled by creating this workflow there's
also an option for you to do object
classification through this step and
essentially the idea is you can chain
together
multiple different options analysis
options within avia within this workflow
processor
now that i've specified all my options
i've clicked on the run option to run
this analysis you could see that there's
a progress bar down below each plate in
our current setup
takes maybe 10 seconds or less and
you can actually view the progress and
the cue option and look at the history
of detected objects so this window is
actually showing you all the detected
objects in the image
now
i can see that the analysis is done and
i can actually open up the newly created
experiment file that has
all the detected objects
displayed on the multi-well setup so in
this case i'm clicking on the first well
a1 first image
and seeing that
the analysis has detected all my desired
objects on the the
cytoplasm the nucleus and the vesicles
and you could see when we just look at
the vesicles in the no agonist condition
there are a lot of uh vesicles and you
can go to the spreadsheet function
to look at different measurements right
now we're looking at cell membrane
measurements now we can move on to
vesicles get individual data points per
object now i'm going to choose a well
you could spot check this way you could
actually look into a well look at the
first field of view here in the agonist
condition
and when we turn off all the other
channels except for the vesicles
let's see i'm turning off the green and
um
blue actually i want the green back and
turn down the lookup table so that i can
actually see you could see that in this
agonist condition there are far fewer
number of
detected vesicles
now we're looking at the newly created
option to export into a
combined csv file that you see here
so you see this excel icon that actually
enables you to export all your
experiment data
per condition you specified per object
creating this
mega csv file that combines
all the data
in individual object type
per condition so that you can actually
do downstream analysis
so the way it works is you click on it
and you click on the location of the
analysis that just
was outputted
and
this button aggregates all your output
into a single csv file
per object per condition
now you can in our case as i mentioned
i'm using cytomap to showcase how to do
downstream analysis
you can search for cytomap
and
i will specify the the location of the
file where um all my
combined csv files are located then i'm
specifying the x
axis is along the centroid x then i
specify the y axis as centroid y
then title map will import
all the data from all the detected
objects in avia into the spreadsheet
once you load the data you could choose
to replace the not available numbers
with zeros which i've done here as the
types of analysis i'd like to work on
down the road
do not allow for zeros and load
once the data are loaded you could
choose any of the options on the left
in this first example for cytomap i've
loaded all the data for both no agonist
agonist groups for all detective
cytoplasmic objects and measurements of
vesicles inside of cytoplasm
i'll be plotting a simple scatter plot
in this case using the new figure button
in this plot you could choose
measurements along which you want to
compare your groups and get your sample
for a specific phenotype that you want
to further analyze in this example i'll
choose area which is the area of each
cytoplasm in the x-axis and contain
vesicle count per cell on the y-axis i'm
then choosing to color code the two drop
conditions by inputting drug along the
z-axis which is for color
once you plot this data
you can see that there are interesting
group differences emerging along the
contained vesicle count axis as we have
already seen in the india by visually
inspecting detected vesicles
now where cytoma enhances that finding
is when you can gate for specific
phenotype of cells by using either the
rectangle or polygon gating tools
you could select
subpopulation of cells using this gating
tool from which you could do subsequent
analysis based on a specific phenotype
of cells you're interested in
next i'll be showing you how to run a
cellular heat map analysis by going to
the extensions menu
as expected we see a diverging finding
on the contained vesicle count dimension
however we have another interesting
finding here where there appears to be
another difference along the mean
vesicle distance to the center of the
cell in these two groups
in this example i've chosen only a small
number of measurements to illustrate the
intended workflow
however when you are working with many
different types of measurements this can
this tool can help you
to narrow down which measurements are
the interesting dimensions to go after
lastly i'll show you a dimensionality
reduction tool inside a map and how you
could use this with measurements from
avia
dimensionality reduction is a rapidly
emerging tool in the field of spatial
biology in this example
i've chosen a multi-well image set where
the absolute xyz coordinates may not be
sensible as measurements
however they're interesting relative
distance measurements such as
the mean vesicle distance to the nuclear
membrane from avia that we can explore
in this example i've chosen umap the
non-linear dimensionality reduction
technique that i discussed earlier
but you could you could choose from
other techniques such as principal
component analysis or t's name
after selecting from the options you can
see how this tool can help to reduce
many number of parameters down to two
for visualization and data
interpretation
here i'm inputting parameters for the um
technique i encourage you to play with
these parameters to see
which
help you to interpret your data better
for instance the end neighbors numbers
can help you focus on local structures
with smaller numbers or on the global
structure with larger numbers
all the features i've shown you today
are also available via aviaweb which is
an additional option
aviaweb enables you to harness the power
of ai tools and avia in the cloud now
with permanent storage without the need
to invest in any powerful hardware
all you need is an internet browser an
internet connection and you can access
avia from anywhere regardless of the
operating system
i want to give special thank you to the
entire avia team who has created all the
features of avia 11 that i have shared
with you today specifically i want to
thank hong yuchang
chicho huang hideki sasaki and hoyan lai
integration casey mcbride for the
experiment explorer implementation
jorgen ryman for his significant review
on spatial biological tools for us to
choose cytomap
casey mcbride and cameron shore for the
cytomap export functionality and john
stansberry for the workflow processor
implementation
i want to also thank the entire qa team
with mike o'shea aidan maloney bertelli
and grace lee for their hard work to
ensure that ada runs as intended
tasmiyah rahman tumpa for insightful
benchmarking
chris biernbaum for his work on the
aviative file formats
maite mcu quen tran hoyn lai and alex
weiss for all things marketing and the
sales and support teams for their
valuable feedback
my special personal thanks to hoyon lai
who has provided endless expertise and
invaluable advice on all things avia
constantine couple for his deep
knowledge on leica product and valuable
advice on scrum
and to sean mcelroy for being the best
scrum master and software team lead one
can ask for
and lastly to luciano lucas for a spark
of insight and continued encouragement
thank you very much
thank you oneyoung for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right so let's get started our first
question here asks can the new workflow
handle 2d and 3d
juan young it looks like you are still
muted there
hello kaylee how are you
um
thank you for that question based on our
initial um pilot studies
we we are fairly confident we can handle
both 2d and 3d applications with our
workflow
great thank you
another question we have here what is
the difference between ml and dl
machine learning and deep learning are
both forms of ai and both are fairly
smart ways of getting problem solved the
difference may be that
machine learning learns by training
whereas um deep learning
can learn from examples much the way
human brains can learn using
a deep neural network
models as i've shown you here
both are exploding avia has examples of
both in our in our in our software and
um i think it will be very we'll be
hard-pressed in 10 years to find
scientific applications that don't
benefit from
some form of ai
great thank you
next question here what about 4d
workflow
based on our current implementation
we we are fairly certain that we can
handle various types of 4d workflow as
well
um because it's we're basically chaining
known um
algorithms and and recipes that work in
avia and
john stansberry has worked very hard to
make this
this workflow to handle as many
applications as possible
great next question here can it be used
on processed or unprocessed tissues that
are not stained
excuse me strained
patients
um
it would be great if we can um get some
more
clarifi clarifying information on the
questions um would that be more for
bright field images tissue sections
cells because we can certainly handle
unstained dic or phase images no problem
it's built into avi
great thank you
all right another question here are all
the features presented today available
to all abs subscribers
yes we're pleased to offer every single
feature i've i've presented here
to any avia subscriber who is
in maintenance so
we wanted to ensure that
the benefits of
avi 11 will be available to anybody
who's using avia today
all right thank you and it looks like
you were able to answer um that previous
question from that last
attendee there so that's great
all right
okay
so it looks like we have time that was
our last question here so thank you
again juan young for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
leica microsystems for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
you